for centuries Mahima past release have
been wandering with the cutting along
the grass plains of central Gander the
unholy are one of the oldest indigenous
cutting breeds their long hauls assist
their blood circulation and help keep
them cool they are in owned for their
hardness which allows them to leave of
poor quality vegetation and limited
amounts of water
for Elizabeth katusha be there more than
a source of income as the person born
from the Bahama community I really
believe that our heritage should not be
lost
I think this cow the uncle a longhorn
cow of Uganda is an identity and it's a
hardy animal in this environment it it's
a boy it's adaptable to our harsh
environment and has actually helped us
protect our environment but the uncle II
have a powerful rival the black and
white checked frisian hostile the
world's predominant dairy cattle bred
for maximum yield the owner of this had
replaced all his and kala cows with
these foreign imports but Frisian horse
strains are fully equipped to deal with
the Ugandan environment forcing the
Hatters to deploy high quantities of
insecticides the only protection against
endemic ticks and parasites since the
introduction of chemical acai sites the
bees left and even other insects and
animals also left since there are no
more beasts we can no longer harvest
honey or so many trees have been cut
here to make space for the cattle there
used to be many trees and there were big
bushes and dust bees used to have the
continuum buzzy as a member of the uncle
a cattle Conservation Association it is
a bit katusha visits farmers across the
country and explains why it is important
to preserve their pure breeds
she convinced farmer Daniel and Emma
hockey to introduce and Kali into his
hats with costs for veterinary medicine
exploding men
Fama's have been evaluating the longhorn
cattle economic value I realize it's
psychology they have believed because
the policy the government policy was to
increase production modernize
agriculture so many of them at a certain
level say oh yeah we get a lot of milk
but really we put a lot of drugs would
buy a lot of chemical sprays for the tea
and we don't really get a lot of money
in Kampala Elizabeth Katusha Bill
Oddie's together with the organization
food Rights Alliance for the government
to take decisive action to preserve the
indigenous species scientists are
concerned the rampant crossbreeding has
severely reduced the population of
purebred and Kali
they fear that Uganda may be sacrificing
a breed with genetic advantages our call
for the protection of our genetic
resources is not for the sake of it it
is an issue of our identity it is an
issue of sustaining our farming systems
it is an issue of sustaining our food
systems it is our issue of what we have
to offer in the global market for
Elisabeth Katusha Bay this is not only a
Ugandan issue across the continent
indigenous livestock species are
punishing the world's food supply is
increasingly dependent on a narrowing
list of highly engineered breeds a
threat to food security and ecological
sustainability so we should find means
and ways of you know living with that
the indigenous breeds because they can
keep the ecosystem properly so we should
not only think about producing a lot of
food but we should think about what kind
of food we are producing with rising
temperatures across the globe and an
environment that is becoming more
inhospitable to the major breeds
humanity might need the genes that allow
animals like the uncle a to flourish in
the African heat